le docteur rochelais a rejoint sos
médecins il y à 12 ans il partage son
quotidien entre les visites à domicile
et les consultations au cabinet de
l'association et ce praticien leur
connaît depuis quelques temps il doit
faire face à des comportements de plus
en plus agressif de patients ou de leurs
proches
oui c'est ça peut être des des
contestations de sur les durées d'arrêt
de travail des des contestations d'une
prescription médicamenteuse comme je
pense c'était le cas l'autre jour temps
pour ma collègue on se rend compte que
oui très vite ça pourrait nous mettre
très fréquemment dans des films dans des
situations compliquées et qu'on peut pas
se battre à longueur de journée comme
tous les praticiens de sos médecins
dijon solidaires de leur collègue
agressé le 30 octobre dernier le docteur
rochelais ne consultera pas à vendredi
une décision que comprend cette patiente
c'est pas normal qu'on viennent agresser
comme ça les médecins elle chaud tout
mais mon cabinet médical encore dans la
rue ou bon il ya dans des zones un peu
difficile ça se comprend très bien mais
là dans la cabine et les médecins et
malgré ses libations signe des
agressions verbales ou physiques comme
mercredi dernier des incivilités envers
les médecins qui se multiplient dans
toute l'agglomération dijonnaise pas
simplement dans certains quartiers comme
tient à le préciser le docteur reda
zerkaoui c'est quelque chose qu'on
rencontre n'importe où et quelles que
soient les milieux sociaux c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment qu'on rencontre
vraiment partout et
je suis avec la schl au ça se passe bien
globalement on a vraiment une bonne
activité à chenôve et on n'a pas de
problème
après un arrêt des visites et des
consultations en journée ce vendredi sos
médecins reprendra son activité à partir
de 20 heures